cuisiner pendant le confinement pour
vous aider les tutos de recettes se
multiplient sur internet
alina on a aussi voulu vous donner
quelques idées disons original recettes
numéro un
les beignets de cervelle et de pommes en
1957 il faisait un tabac
et attention le choix des cervelles a
son importance
voici trois servent elles différentes
unes de vos croatie me dire si la plus
grosse au oui de beaucoup de porc qui
est celle ci qui est un peu plus allongé
les plus longues et une de moutons que
voici
qu est ce qu est la plus ronde oui après
avoir fait frire les pommes et les
cervelles place au dressage
alors les heures on va le sucré voyez
vous avec le sucre glace ici très très
abondamment y les autres cela nous
allons les salles est très légèrement
qu'elle est présentée également sur un
soutien à nous habiller en leur disant
vous veniez recettes numéro 2 le
sandwich géant en 1967 le cuisinier
michel ollivier partager cet en-cas très
gourmand au milieu tu vas mettre les
cacahuètes
mélanger avec le chômage alors dessus en
remet le bain
hélas alors là nous allons mettre ton
poulet dernière étape de la recette et
non des moindres tartiner généreusement
les sandwichs de pro maj frais voilà et
bien tout le reste c'est pour recettes
numéro 3 l'estomac de porc farci
mon dieu un estomac ne porte pas c'est
ça une recette alsacienne présenté en
1981 les ingrédients des pommes de terre
de la poitrine de porc salé poireaux des
carottes du chou le tout bien parti dans
un bel estomac de porcs dont pour en
pousser très serré mais pas trop serré
quand même pas trop serré compte sinon
ça va éclater à la crise en recettes
numéro 4
le hamburger signé maïté une recette que
vous ne trouverez dans aucun livre de
cuisine sapho promet et la recette est
généreuse entre ces deux morceaux de
pain xxl rajouter quelques feuilles de
salade et surtout du gras beaucoup de
gras de faire revenir mon foie gras mais
malgré les jets 10 avant qu'on avait
installé sur la jolie salade ça va de
soi fosses de sable
bon on n'en parlera pas ce que c'est bon
ça nourrit un nourrisson nombre
hamburger géant baigné de cervelle ou
estomac farsi maintenant à vous de jouer
[Musique]